- So, ihr Lieben.
Heute werden wir für euch unser
erstes verrückt
klingendes Gericht kochen.
Wenn ihr Ideen, Fragen oder Anregungen
habt – lasst es uns wissen!
- Das ganze Rezept
und die Zutaten dazu haben wir euch
in die Beschreibung geschrieben.
Und wie das alles zubereitet wird,
zeigen wir euch in dem Video.
- Dieses Mal gibt es „Himmel und Erde“.
Das ist ein Gericht aus der
westfälischen Region,
im Westen Deutschlands.
- Dazu
werden zuerst die Kartoffeln geschält,
gewaschen
und ein bisschen klein geschnitten.
- Übrigens:
So alt und traditionell kann
das Gericht gar nicht sein.
Denn:
Die Kartoffel ist zwar
mittlerweile „typisch Deutsch“,
aber ihr Ursprung liegt
gar nicht in Deutschland.
- Ist das so?
- Ja.
Ursprünglich kommt die Kartoffel
aus Südamerika,
aber mittlerweile gibt es sie natürlich
in jedem Gewächshaus
und in jedem Supermarkt.
Gut für alle, die „Himmel und Erde“
machen wollen.
- Hallo, 'tschuldigung!
- Ha, jetzt kann ich das
alles nochmal erzählen!
- Das interessiert
doch sowieso niemanden.
- Doch, das ist total spannend.
- Ja, sicher …
- Entschuldigung, ich wollte nicht stören.
- Ja, zu spät.
Was …
was wollen Sie hier?
- Ich weiß, Sie mögen mich nicht,
weil ich Inge belogen habe.
Aber
lassen Sie es mich wiedergutmachen!
Ich liebe Inge.
Von ganzem Herzen.
- Na, dann sagen Sie ihr das.
- Sie hört mir nicht zu.
- Wir lassen die ganze Zeit laufen.
- Das ist Pech.
- Vielleicht will sie Ihnen zuhören!
Ich flehe Sie an. Helfen Sie mir!